Now let's look at the main
web security issues.
The browser accepts contents and
often runs dynamic contents
such as scripts from websites.
The question is,
can a browser trust these contents.
In some cases, the browser can
authenticate the website, but
in many cases,
authentication is not required.
But even if a website is authenticated,
the contents that it sends may not
be trustworthy because the website may
have security vulnerabilities that
allow attackers to inject malicious
contents that get passed to the browser.
Or the website includes contents or
links to other websites which may
also have security vulnerabilities.
On the server side a website runs
applications that process requests from
browsers and often interacts with
back-end servers to produce content for
users.
These web applications,
like any software,
may have security vulnerabilities.
Furthermore, many websites
do not authenticate users.
That is, attackers are not prevented
from sending requests designed to
exploit the security vulnerabilities
in these web applications.